In many cases it's a substance properties as well as genetic factors play a role
in adverse health effect.
This us as they explored her conditions of are important.
For example,
primos chemical exposures such as smoking or alcohol abuse can play a large role
in disease.
Develop age is another key factor.
Children,
elderly often most susceptible to diseases in case of children fast ingestion
rate compared to that body weight.
A person and poor health is always the most susceptible to environmental risks
because their body is already out of alignment and no longer exists in
homeostasis.
Of course some people are just more predisposed or resistant to certain forms of
infection or sort of forms of contaminant.
However,
that does not help us on a large scale in green chemistry because as a rule they
also get all these have to take care of the least resistant proportion of the
population and therefore we're able to design chemicals that did not produce
Heather's into narcos risks to everyone.
Equally obviously in the real world are exposed to many chemical companies at
the same time.
Everything that chemical and in some rate or another,
it is likely to enter your body.
However,
the different combination of chemicals can have very different effects.
For example,
cigarette smoke and heavy as best as as porter multiply the risk of cancer and
in this case chemical exposure does not work like math two plus two equals two
four.
The three types of basic chemical interaction is there is antagonism when one
chemical is reduces the fact of another.
That is the function of antidotes,
antidotes,
uh,
I'm taking this sticks to the effect of poisons is therefore to reduce the
effect of the poison and keep you alive.
Additive toxicity.
It is simply that when you exposed to two chemicals,
it is like edit concentration of the two chemicals together.
So alcohol and aspirin add together to increase toxicity.
Finally does it as a synergistic effect.
Synergistic effect makes things a lot a lot worst,
such as as best as in smoking,
as best as damages,
lungs smoking can further that effect by interacting with the damaged tissue in
a different way and therefore causing cancer progression.
Pesticides and fertilizer act in much the same way.
Where exporter to Bose multiplies the effect.
We don't exist in a world where we're exposed to one chemical in a controlled
environment,
when in just existed in natural laboratory or whatever,
exposed to [inaudible] of chemicals all the time.
So as the interactions,
while my daughter always be important can play a key role,
just like interaction,
self,
environment with your genetics.